[Musique]
on va augmenter les transferts en santé
dans une anja stable prévisible et sans
conditions avec une monte à près de 60
milliards de dollars est-ce que ça se
traduira vraiment par un financement
supplémentaire de 60 milliards sur 10
ans pas nécessairement la formule
actuelle se base sur la croissance
économique et prévoit une augmentation
des transferts d'au moins 3% par année
si la croissance économique est faible
la hausse promise par les conservateurs
pourrait représenter un gain de 60
milliards de dollars pour les provinces
mais si elle est forte le guen pourrait
être plus faible comparativement à la
formule actuelle
on a investi assez d'argent pour qu'on
soit en tête de lice dans la planète en
termes de vaccination le canada est-il
parmi les premiers la réponse est oui 67
% des canadiens sont complètement
vaccinés
le canada arrive au premier rang des
pays du g7 et au 10e rang mondial en
termes de vaccination
en six ans vous avez le pire bilan du
sheed g7 le canada est il le seul pays
du g7 où les émissions de gaz à effet de
serre ont grimpé dans une dernière année
oui c'est vrai lorsque les libéraux sont
arrivés au pouvoir en 2015 le canada a
rejeté 723 médias tonnes de gaz à effet
de serre
quatre ans plus tard ce nombre grimper à
730 mégatonnes les états unis le royaume
uni l'allemagne la france l'italie et le
japon ont tous réussi à réduire leurs
émissions pendant cette période après
toutes ces années là il n'a pas trouvé
les moyens de déployer rapidement les
ressources financières humaines et en
infrastructures pour qu'il y ait de
l'eau sur des communautés autochtones
c'est vrai les libéraux ne sont pas
parvenus à régler tous les problèmes
d'approvisionnement en eau potable dans
les réserves autochtones en cinq ans
comme il s'y était engagé
109 avis à long terme concernant la
qualité de l'eau potable ont été levés
depuis novembre 2015 mais il en reste 51
en vigueur ici olivier bachand réseau
canada montréal